[Music]
brittany's in houston texas hey brittany
how are you
hi dave hi chris i'm really honored to
be able to pick your brains for a minute
cool how can we help my question is my
questions about our budget
um so we've been davish for a long time
my husband and i we've been married 10
years
we have three kids um so davish i
i can say does not work you probably
have to be all in to really get the
benefit
um we were debt-free a year ago and then
my husband's truck got stolen
and if we only have liability no
comprehensive so no insurance payout on
that
and we decided to buy a minivan
and so now we have a car loan for the
first time in a long time
we've had it for about a year and it
feels kind of crushing so we've decided
to go into real
dave methods here and get started but
i'm looking at our budget and i want to
know
what is reasonable to keep in our budget
what makes sense for our family and
what do we have to cut and are we
shooting ourselves in the foot
by not going beans and rice rice and
beans
all the way what is your household
income
my husband he's a sole provider he's a
first responder and
so he works 84 to 96 hours a week and he
brings in
a little over 5000 a month okay so 60
000 a year
and what do you owe on the van
we owe 24 000. sell it
okay stupid van
yeah it did not bring you happiness
the word you used was crushing the word
you used was crushing when something is
crushing me
i try to get out from under it so that
it doesn't crush me
right that makes sense yeah that's not
like
the answer that feels fun but that's
it is not only the right answer but more
importantly what are you going to do
you guys have been davis you said before
so what are you going to do
are you tiptoeing around this thing and
is this van going to roll money out of
your
life every month are you going to take a
stand
what are you going to do
listen i i'm um
one of my favorite one of my favorite
verses is the blessings
of the lord have no sorrow
added to them this van
the way you described it there's a lot
of sorrow associated with it
you feel ashamed that you shouldn't have
bought it you feel regret
that you did buy it you look at the math
and it makes you want to puke
it's crushing was the word you used
and so this i think i think we can
pretty clearly say this is not from god
it's not a
blessing that god sent into your life
and so
let's pull it like it's a bad splinter
in your finger
and get your life back honey it's not
going to affect me
i you you get to do ramsay-ish if you
want to ramsey issue
you know here's the thing it does not
affect my
personal trainer if i do 45 sit-ups with
him
and then i go eat a box of chocolate
donuts it doesn't affect him
that's true but i'm not following
instructions and i'm not going to get
the results
that he has that's why i keep having a
keg and he has a six-pack
you know because i'm trainer-ish
you have to you have to do the thing you
want that's gonna get you the thing you
want you do
you gotta you know it's um and you gotta
you guys gotta look at that and decide
it's up to you
i'm not mad at you you do whatever you
wanna do but you said
it's crushing you and you know it's
illogical
to stay under something that is falling
on your head that's right
somebody dropped that thing off a bridge
you would move move quickly you wouldn't
stand
under it and get crushed not at all not
at all
and i know you said your husband truck
got stolen
so you guys are feeling all this but
listen don't don't bring that dead in
your life
reject it yeah and then sit down and do
your budget i'll tell you what we'll put
you in uh ramsay plus
and you guys get into financial peace
university and get your budget going
on every dollar and you'll start to see
the other areas that you can cut
but i mean this is not this is not a
blessing
the blessings of the lord have no sorrow
added to them if an item
a situation is giving you sorrow then
you know it wasn't from god that's a
good point